and lo everyone berry here with another
Sundance 2019 interview brought to you
by the Kia Telluride huge thanks to them
for making all this happen because we
love talking movies and this one is a
special one it's love antosha it's a
documentary about Anton Yelchin life and
I will tell you guys right now I have
always been a huge fan of his and I'm
very grateful that we have this and we
have this behind-the-scenes look at his
passion and his career so thank you for
making it and thank you for being here I
was wondering when the idea came up to
first tell his story through the
documentary format was it from you was
it his family that maybe brought it up
so long story so basically have two
hours remember yeah after Anton passed
away his parents just started gathering
archival material interviews letters
everything with the hopes of one day
they may be making a documentary I
didn't know you know just just archiving
basically and then they get to a point
where I think they were ready to hand
over to a filmmaker they reached out to
Drake because of how close he was with
Anton and he'd stay close to the family
and to Drake's credit he felt himself
too close to the story the subject to so
basically reached out to me and
introduced me to the Elton's and thought
I could give an objective story day in
town and make something authentic and
truthful that's the way he would have
wanted it
and Garretson editor yeah we went to
film school together 17 years ago at AFI
and this is his first directorial debut
he directed and edited the film and it's
got such a singular voice and I think
what's so amazing about the oceans is
they really allowed Garrett in this
process to be completely uncompromising
and it's a very truthful honest portrait
it's not a gloss over run in the middle
documentary it's a very unique film and
I think that's a credit to the oh should
Santa Garrett for finding his voice in
the film as a director for the first
time you definitely feel it in putting
together all of the footage that you
guys have did you ever play around with
the format at all or did you always want
to go step-by-step through his life in
the career I wanted to tell
coming-of-age story because aunt
for the movies and that's that is what
it feels like I didn't know how to
describe it before but that's that's
what this is it's a coming-of-age
documentary the first thing I saw was
that little journal he wrote about his
first kiss
during hearts of Atlantis and I was like
this is a coming-of-age story and then
him getting drunk during AlphaDog I mean
these all these things you experience
from a child to a teenager he was doing
it for the love of his craft when she
slashed onto and I was like the story
has to be told why why did you choose
this for your feature directorial debut
it did something feel right for you with
this there was so much material and as
an editor it's I mean that's a blessing
you know it's a treasure trove of stuff
to work with so as I started digging in
I started discovering the effect he had
on people through his life I was I
wanted to make a movie how I felt when I
discovered Anton through this because I
didn't know Anton personally I knew him
through drake's movies and Star Trek
roles but I just mesmerized but complex
and multifaceted and a layered human he
was and I think a lot of people were
really surprised yeah he was a musician
tog referre
I mean he's just there's so many facets
to his creativity it was just sprawling
was so sprawling so it's like I think a
lot of people are gonna be very shocked
and surprised to learn a lot of things
they just had no idea about right I had
interviewed him a few times and I got
certain vibes from him that made me
think I knew a little bit about who he
was behind the scenes but not nearly to
the extent that you guys show us in this
in this film here but the other thing
was just how into film he was and how
passionate he was and how you show how
his passion influenced others and
especially I don't know sitting here at
Sundance of all places where it's about
celebrating filmmakers and the craft it
feels really important that this movie
is premiering here very much so very
much so I mean there's no other place in
the world this movie could have
premiered or should have premiered and
it's so special that that this is
Anton's last film at Sundance I mean
it's just so surreal and emotional and
important and hopefully really inspiring
I mean you know I think a lot of people
think and are worried the movie's sad
but at the end of the day it's not it's
a really inspiring tale about creativity
and about artistry and about chaos and
about your own demons and things like
that and anyone who's ever created
anything I think can relate to it and
living life to its fullest because is
the
initially life to its fullest admittedly
I walked into it a little nervous that I
was gonna be motional II overwhelmed but
dream on I was but not in the way that I
thought I would and that's how we want
to frame it for audiences going in very
much so yeah that's a that's a really
nice touch and I think kind of leads
into another question that I wanted to
ask you guys his passing wasn't all that
long ago so why now for something like
this and why do you feel like the doctor
documentary format is I guess needed to
share his story why now I think martin
landau in our film actually says the
best we live in a very fast world now
and he just doesn't want to be forgotten
and that's kind of the mantra i took
through this we made it fairly quickly -
we just wanted to get out get out there
i think in your second question i think
people are just looking for real
authentic stories in this world now you
know i think especially comes portraits
of people people they can relate to and
latch on to and i think that's why there
is this sudden surge authentic and
inspiring and you took both those boxes
here i wanted to hear a little bit about
your collaboration on this because
you've worked together before but now
you're in the director's chair so is
there anything you discovered about each
other it was being filmmakers that
surprised you learned a lot about each
other and how to push each other to make
each other better and had i grow and how
to learn i mean we met 17 years ago at
AFI and i've been working together on
and off over the years and different
projects different ings like that and
he's got a lot of great documentaries
and done a lot of different things i
wanted a lot of different things and
then this project kind of brought us
back together and was the perfect thing
and then now we're he's editing my new
movie right now that we're in the middle
of working on so it's just kind of a
really fun thing it's not about you know
who's right or who's wrong or whose job
is what it's more about just trying to
make the best film possible and
collaborate in a really freeform way and
be [ __ ] honest with each other that's
the best part of our relationship is
like there isn't after seventeen years
there's nothing we can't like or feel
there's no kid gloves ever and you want
that in a collaborator more than
anything and it's funny I don't think a
day goes by where we don't talk about
Anton and his project he's always with
us and I think through this project I
think everything we make in this is
thinking about how like how do we dig
deeper the way he would have done
exactly well that's the thing I think I
walked away with more so than anything
especially being in not the same side of
the end
stray bits still being a part of it you
know looking at certain movies a
specific way and thinking you know how
would he analyze it in a way that I
might not yeah I think that's a great
that's a great really nice touch you
were talking about the wealth of footage
and material that you got from his
family so I imagine it's not the longest
documentary in the world you can't
include any of everything there so is
there anything that came out of the
final cut that you still want people to
know about or maybe experience on a DVD
or bluray down the line I mean yeah a
little bit bigger deeper in terms of
music I there's so many interviews that
are amazing that we just couldn't fit in
you know how many people wanted to be a
part of it but 60 plus interviews in the
end everybody was just jumping to be a
part of it and share their stories and
talk about his life and how they
infected him and how I mean everybody in
the film their life was just completely
changed by him it's like he anytime he
came into your life he would just change
you forever he was just that kind of
special soul and whether in professional
life or personal life everyone was the
same Dan towns which I loved also this
perspective sitting down and I mean you
guys must know how it is do these
interviews over and over and when you
you talk to someone and you feel that
genuine passion and drive and they want
to be there celebrating what they worked
on right sticks with you and he had that
effect on people for the process of
accumulating all of your interviews how
do you come up with that list you sit
down and and jot down all the people
he's worked with and didn't just go
that's victory that's his parents they
you know they were key and getting these
interviews and I think that's why
because of their involvement in this
even though they gave us complete
autonomy to tell a story
the subjects knowing that their
involvement I think that's why we got
such unguarded and authentic and
truthful interviews it's interviews I
don't think you see a lot of times in
films like they're so honest they're so
honest there's so many stories that you
maybe would be like slightly
inappropriate but that was Anton's life
he had a dark side hit ever had a very
you know sexual side which is which is
expressed in the movie as well which I
think is so cool and interestingly you
don't normally see yeah how was it how
was it working with his parents because
thus far it does sound like they were
very excited about this project very
collaborative did you get to sit down
with them early on and just understand
what they
wanted to get out of this documentary
both for themselves personally but also
in terms of his legacy I don't think
there's anything personal about it for
them they just want his legacy to go on
honestly this is a tool for them to have
and to spread the gospel of Anton and
keep him alive because he's alive with
them and it's great and I love it
I'd loved we've given them something to
do it's very special you know I mean
it's just I can't imagine losing a child
and in the what with that and I mean I
can't even imagine that but you know the
fact that this is something that they're
going to be able to spend hopefully a
year going around the world and talking
about him at different film festivals or
different different events we can screen
the movie and you know the every dime
the movie makes goes towards his
foundation for cystic fibrosis and and
all of his artwork and music and all
those things that all just kind of
rolled into one and just continuing to
help others while also spreading the
word about how inspiring it was I'm sure
so many fans of his are gonna go out and
see this movie because having seen his
work but I'm kind of hoping that they
also bring people who aren't familiar
yes that's very important this this is
basically like you know a snapshot of
his filmography and it could most
certainly inspire people to seek out his
way I think one of these things I just
don't want to be defined by the way he
passed away I think a lot of people know
that there's not so much it's such a
small part of this is a film about life
and it really people need to know the
life you lived speaking of his
impression on the two of you you just
brought up the project you're working on
together and I was wondering during that
process that's still ongoing actually is
there anything that you guys found
yourselves doing specifically that came
through your relationship with Anton or
your experience just making the movie
about anything everyday I mean um you
know all of my films are improvised and
Anton's an incredible improviser and
he's he's so amazing and in my film I
think and you know I learned so much
from him about how how to approach the
process on how to become friends I mean
we became such close friends and and now
because of that I feel like I seek out
to become close friends with all the
people in my films and to maintain those
relationships and how important those
relationships are it's not just about
executing a film or an idea it's about
the exploration together as human beings
and
Matt funnels its way into the work and
that's what I learned from him the most
and that's why an hour from now I became
very close with my cast shailene
Woodley's fashion stand and and it's
just like um you know it's it's the it's
the purpose its the purpose is to infect
each other's lives in such a positive
way and challenge each other and to
learn and grow and that's what I
intended for me and that's what I put
into everyday of what I do now a little
bit of the film school vibe - it's the
only way to do it
it's the only way to do that's yeah
that's a really nice touch to any movie
I mean you you pour so much time in your
life and your soul and your energy and
your creativity into something and I
don't understand why anyone would walk
on a set and take it as work like you're
going to your jet like no you're going
to make a movie with your family for a
little well so especially when Anton -
is he he had so much fun doing it and
everybody whether you were the DP where
you were crafty or a PA you were
laughing with him all day and then we go
do the work and it's so serious but it's
like he would just his laughs and and
the amount of funny hat and making
making fun of himself and situations and
everything I mean he just had so much
fun with it yeah I think we're pretty
much levity in your film he would anton
say well yeah so funny yeah
with everybody you interviewed because
you're talking about how he influenced
everyone out there we see a lot of his
very recognizable co-stars but did
anybody kind of come out and reach out
to you that wanted to be a part of this
documentary that maybe caught you by
surprise a little I don't mean a gas
station attendant I think everyone was
just waiting to be asked that they
honestly and in the moment they were
they were a part of it they were they
were add and then you know the biggest
get in the end we started framing this
was Nic Cage to do his to read his words
and was there were kindred spirits in
many ways and the idea that Anton would
have made a lot of similar choices the
Nick made in his career and would be in
that place his
kind of perfect it's perfect match and
as we wind down here I kind of told you
a little bit about what I took from this
but just in your own words for anybody
out there who comes across this
documentary what do you hope they walk
away from love and Tasha with you're
gonna feel inspired I think and that's I
think we also talked about like calling
your parents yeah I mean you know it's
such a love letter to his parents in
their relationship and reaching out to
the people that you love and then are
important in your life and spending
meaningful time with them and what that
means and digging deeper into into
everything that you do and why you do it
in searching I would go home every day I
look at my children I'd be like why
aren't you guys that treating me like
the way Anton treats well thank you guys
so much for taking your time to come in
here to anything thank you for making
this movie because again it was
important to me as a fan of his and I
imagine it's important to many other
people out there who had all sorts of
relationships with him so thank you guys
for your time to watch it
thank you everybody for watching this
interview please like and share it
another thank you to Kia Telluride for
helping make this happen
we will have more Sundance 2019 coverage
for you real soon
you